you've got this podcast that uh people
really do enjoy
i find it to be hilarious it's called uh
bananas for bonanza
yes that's right and that's it's
actually a podcast that the character
dalton wilcock
is in he is the host of bananas for
bonanza
along with uh the great matt gourley as
he plays character named mutt taylor
country music legend mutt taylor
and maria bamford is on there as a
christian entrepreneur named amy
sliverson
and the three of them are super fans
of the short-lived television western
series bonanza that sam
are not short-lived at all sadly well
that you know that show only had 431
episodes it was only on
it was only on during the 50s 60s and
70s yeah
it's uh so they each episode they go
uh they focus they do a deep dive on an
episode of bonanza we talk about it
scene by scene
we really get in depth there's a lot of
these shows
right now podcasts where people go over
real shows and this is sort of a
satirical take
on that and you guys talk about bonanza
and it's uh it's a very funny show
i'm curious if you've heard from actual
fans of bonanza do they know that this
exists
i would have to say no
which is good they might not like it
it's hard to find the real fans of
bonanza although there is there's a
uh a website there's a forum uh called
uh
bonanzaboomers.com and i check in with
it every once in a while just waiting
for somebody to post on there hey
there's a podcast
where each episode is devoted to an
episode of the show we all love
but so far they have not discovered it
no well i'll tell you what my brother
neil
is a huge fan of bonanza wow and he has
a um encyclopedic knowledge of that show
and whenever i'm with him he makes me
watch a couple of them so i know a lot
more about bonanza than you would ever
imagine
oh really well it is a fascinating show
we've learned a few things we're only 12
episodes in and
apparently it constantly happens that
one of the cartwrights
develops a love interest who seems like
she's going to move to the ponderosa and
be a permanent member of the cast
and she always dies always gets killed
yeah every one of them says i like her
and i might want to marry
her at before the episode she's killed
yeah one of them got a pitchfork to the
side and one of them like
they've been dying of diseases and yeah
it's been fascinating and then the other
thing is that
about half the episodes or maybe a third
of the episodes like this story
cannot accommodate all four of the
regular members of the cast so the very
first scene is two of the characters
going
well we're off to california good luck
right
right right you're not getting paid this
week yeah exactly
uh well people should check that out
because it really is uh very funny uh
make sure i get
get the word out uh bananas for bonanza
yeah wherever you get your podcasts
what's that i was just going to point
out the bananas is spelled correctly
b-o-n-a-n-a-s yes
b-o yes bananas for bonanza
bonannas for bonanza and uh i just say
bananas
but exactly that's how i say it review
the complete series dvd is out now
check that out yeah it's exclusive to
amazon that's where you'll find it
and then uh i think you and i when we do
get our hair cut should get it cut
together
i think that's a great idea my children
are begging to cut my hair but i don't
see that
how i would come out of that with both
ears is yours getting long in the back
mine's starting to get
there's a lot back here it's quite long
back there
uh yeah we are two very pretty girls
i know i i i think i could do period
pieces i could be a corporate stooge as
long as it's an early 70s
yes yes i could say sir we can't afford
to put seat belts on all of our cars
that's an outrageous idea sir it'll
never work
yeah and this is 1971. exactly
uh andy you're a good man why thank you
um a fine man i've recently learned
that uh when receiving a compliment it's
a good idea to also return the
compliment so i think you're you're
you're
you're fine you're fine
uh that's all the time we have andy
thank you so much
nice talking to you be safe be well
thank you i really enjoyed that thanks
for doing it
you